eight at 607 on your Wednesday morning
let's talk about what's driving you
crazy and the Regional Transportation
Commission wants you to let them know if
there's a hinky traffic signal on your
commute
well viewer Susan writes the left turn
signal from eastbound Craig to
Northbound Clayton sometimes doesn't
kick in often going through three Cycles
before giving the turn arrow backing up
traffic causing a dangerous situation
when cars pull out of the turn lane to
go through the main light no particular
time of day I've been stuck morning noon
and evening
Susan I've let the RTC traffic signal
folks know about your concern they're
looking into it but you know what
there's a cool phone number to know
because with the hundreds of signals
under their watch 24 7 they want you to
give them a heads up if any particular
light needs to be looked at here it is
702-901-8400 now we mentioned this in a
recent report but you know not everybody
watches the news all the time and don't
worry if you don't have time to write
down this number it's in the online
version of the story when you visit
8newsnow.com you click traffic and then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put on that phone you
can join the drive any crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com